[Music]
have you ever thought about picard
carelessly risking the lives of children
the riots on earth a couple years from
now or whether starfleet foots the bill
for o'brien's therapy sessions maybe
it's time you do these are the
questionable things we ignore in star
trek from the earliest days of star trek
nearly every race we've met has
resembled ourselves vulcans klingons
romulans and even the borg they're all
just like us except for the makeup and
prosthetics
sure some have forehead ridges bumps and
scales but only on rare occasions have
we seen genuinely unique aliens
some of the few exceptions to this
relative uniformity include the shelliak
in the next generation episode the
incense of command and species 10c in
star trek discovery for a fictional
universe where there is seemingly no end
to intelligent life it's truly
remarkable that nearly every race our
characters have encountered is generally
composed of carbon-based humanoid bipeds
beyond that almost all of them can live
in an oxygen atmosphere
star trek tried to explain this in the
season 7 episode of the next generation
titled the chase
there we learned that billions of years
ago an ancient race of humanoid aliens
seeded countless worlds with their dna
guiding the evolution of other species
to their shape and form
it was a half-hearted retcon that didn't
make a lot of sense and wasn't even
necessary because viewers also realize
that producing a weekly science fiction
series like star trek doesn't always
grant the luxury of crafting expensive
alien special effects however it remains
a bit difficult for the audience to
ignore the question of why everyone
looks so human even non-trekkies know
that vulcans are a logical and
emotionless race of people klingons are
a race of mighty warriors and romulans
are scheming villains
dedicated fans know that the ferengi are
greedy and motivated by profit while the
borg only want to assimilate however in
the real world humans make up an
inherently diverse society with a
variety of different attitudes interests
personalities and traditions yet on star
trek it often seems like every alien
race is described in surprisingly
singular terms of all the species we've
made contact with yours is the only one
we can't define
sure later star trek shows tried to
expand the characterization of vulcans
klingons and romulans by introducing
factions among them with different
beliefs and goals still those retcons
don't change the fundamental depiction
of these groups as a whole
beyond that when star trek introduces a
new planet or race of people they are
quick to describe them in singular terms
the real world explanation is that it's
a simple shorthand to deliver the meat
of the story to audiences which explains
why viewers don't often question it
nevertheless for a series built off of
diversity most of its alien races are
anything but
according to star trek lore the united
federation of planets was founded by
four alien races humans vulcans
telerites and andorians over the
centuries the organization has grown to
include more than 150 distinct planetary
governments and worlds
despite this the overwhelming majority
of crew members we see on federation
starships are human sure every series
has a token alien or two on the bridge
however while there are ostensibly a
handful of non-humans serving on many
federation ships we hardly ever see any
of them and it's almost always humans
milling around the corridors it took
until season three of discovery in fact
for a series to star an alien captain
if the organization is supposed to
represent the entire federation
we can't help but wonder why their ships
all seem to be so human-centric
once again this is almost certainly a
budgetary issue but when one stops for
even a moment to think about it it makes
you wonder if starfleet has an inherent
terrestrial bias
for a franchise that claims to be all
about diversity inclusion and equal
rights star trek has had some surprising
moments of sexism and misogyny in its
long history despite having a
high-ranking black woman serving on the
bridge controversial in its day
the original series too often made its
women out to be helpless and incompetent
this problem goes beyond the outmoded
attitudes of the 1960s that seeped into
the original series and continues with
the 1990s spin-offs even when the next
generation tried to make a statement on
the objectification of women in the
episode the perfect mate it turned into
a message about respecting the
traditions of other cultures subtly
condoning the misogyny at the center of
the story deep space nine did better as
characters are rarely defined solely by
their gender and female crew members
explore complex layered stories of their
own but voyager was another matter
despite having the franchise's first
woman in the captain's chair the series
was rife with subtle sexism in the
episode retrospect they went so far as
to victim blame seven of nine after an
apparent assault
meanwhile many fans on reddit felt that
nelix's relationship with the much
younger and naive kes bordered on
abusive
hollow decks were one of the first major
new pieces of tech introduced to
audiences in star trek the next
generation
as a holographic simulator room the
holodeck can create a convincing
life-like environment
users can visit anything from a 19th
century london street to the valley of
chula on romulus
employed for both leisure and training
purposes it allowed the series to
explore strange new worlds within the
ship itself and offered up plenty of
opportunities for drama aren't you
taking clive's death a little seriously
after all he was just a sweep character
the problem is nearly every time we see
the holodeck it's malfunctioning whether
it's the result of a random power surge
radiation from a nearby star or a crew
member creating a super villain with a
set of cryptic instructions it seems as
if nothing ever goes right on the
holodeck even the slightest malfunction
automatically shuts off the system's
safety protocols that prevent injury and
death taking the hollow deck from an
innocent and leisurely respite room to
an artificially intelligent kill box
starfleet never seemed interested in
making it safer either
on voyager and deep space nine
malfunctions on hollow decks and hollow
suites are still causing problems they
are easily manipulated too allowing
anyone with ill intent to turn them into
elaborate death traps considering how
often things go wrong on the holodeck we
should be questioning why anyone in
starfleet would ever set foot in one
even in the earliest days of star trek
the crew of the enterprise goes back and
forth through time like they are headed
down the street for a cup of coffee
in the city on the edge of forever the
crew visits a planet with a living
portal that allows mccoy kirk and spock
to travel back to 1930s new york
after a mix-up and a fix-up they depart
and do nothing to warn other passing
ships of the portal they don't even
contact starfleet to protect or research
this valuable new found gateway time
travel is featured heavily in the movie
star trek 4 the voyage home where it
appears even less consequential all it
takes is some mathematical calculations
and a slingshot around the sun and
blammo they're back in 1986. it can't be
that simple and painless could it star
trek picard uses this method again in
the series second season but at least
that is done to repair the timeline
eventually starfleet wises up and
creates the temporal prime directive
however time travel continues to be
treated as if it were largely
unremarkable
time travel since my first day on the
job as a starfleet captain i swore i'd
never let myself get caught in one of
these god-forsaken paradoxes
even the advent of the department of
temporal investigations doesn't seem to
do much to slow down the number of time
travel incidents we see in the franchise
like transporters the universal
translator is an essential piece of star
trek technology that we are almost
required to accept without question
though it may not have been invented by
star trek the franchise certainly
popularized the concept of a device that
instantly translates all communication
unlike the telepathic field that
converts languages in doctor who the
universal translator is a technological
device carried by every crew member it's
also embedded in every ship's
communication system allowing characters
and the audience to understand each
other despite speaking their own native
alien languages
however it's never made clear how they
work and the few times they've delved
into those details it doesn't really add
up is it a physical communicator with a
speaker that translates in real time
does it mute the person's voice do you
hear them speaking in their language
with the translation overlapping or do
you see the person's mouth moving out of
sync
in early episodes it's shown as a
handheld device
while one deep space 9 episode sees
ferengi characters describe the tech as
small enough to be hidden deep inside
their ears
and yet despite still knowing very
little about how the universal
translators work they've continued to be
a key element in a number of stories
every time the show tries to deal with
it it only creates more questions
believing us wishing they'd hand wave it
as vague science because ultimately it's
the kind of questionable aspect of star
trek that is best left ignored
when star trek the next generation first
launched in 1987 it boasted several
notable differences from its 1960s
parent series
instead of a young dashing fist first
captain kirk we meant the diplomatic
contemplative and stern captain picard
not only was there a new crew but there
was a new starship too
the updated enterprise d was bigger
faster and more powerful but it included
a surprising addition
families and children
this new ship could also separate in
times of battle with the saucer section
which housed hundreds of civilians
including children of all ages and an
entire school system able to zip off
under its own power
more often than not the enterprise d
found itself in conflicts with the
klingons romulans or the borg but never
bothered to get the saucer section to
safety
in fact during the show's entire seven
season run it only successfully
separates three times thankfully it does
separate in the film generations when
the ship's warp core destroys the rest
of the vessel with so many civilians on
board it would seem that the captain
should immediately separate the ship and
get them to safety before entering a
potentially dangerous situation why
picard doesn't do that is anyone's guess
commander shelby prepared to initiate
your plan to separate the saucer section
when we find the board
when it launched in 1966 the 1990s must
have seemed far enough out after all
radio was a dominant medium just decades
ago so they might not have suspected
television would last into the next
millennium let alone take their little
science fiction series along with it as
such the writers of star trek didn't
hesitate to establish a fictional
history of the rest of the 20th century
and beyond this included a global
conflict in the 1990s called the
eugenics wars during which the
genetically engineered tyrant khan nune
and singh ruled more than half the
planet a third world war was said to
have taken place in the early part of
the 21st century while later series
mentioned missions to mars and civil
unrest across the planet in 2024 even
though some of that could still come to
pass much of the fictional history of
star trek no longer matches up with the
real world newer shows like star trek
voyager and star trek ricard which see
characters travel back to our present
have tried glossing over those details
or retconing events
unfortunately for the series but
fortunately for us the fact remains that
star trek can no longer reconcile the
history of their fictional earth with
our real one
many episodes of star trek have included
or been built around characters going
through traumatic events
these shocking incidents include kirk
being forced to let the woman he loves
die in city on the edge of forever and
picard's imprisonment by cardassians in
chain of command however in almost every
instance the enterprises officers are
back on duty right away as if nothing
happened they are not given time to
recover and we rarely hear how they're
dealing with what they've been through
the next generation does dedicate an
entire episode to picard's recovery from
his assimilation by the borg and family
but he is still in command of the
enterprise once he is de-assimilated in
fairness much of this is due to the
episodic structure of the earlier shows
which largely avoided longer serialized
arcs however even on deep space nine
where serialization is standard chief
o'brien is regularly put through the
ringer he is tortured by cardassians
virtually imprisoned for two decades and
regularly suffers some of the worst
incidents the show presents yet each
week he is back on duty as soon as he
returns to the station you'd think by
the 24th century starfleet would have
more enlightened attitudes toward
dealing with workplace stress you'd
think they'd mandate recovery time or
treatment to keep their officers in peak
mental shape however it seems like in
the world of star trek you are mostly
expected to be back to work immediately
after undergoing severe trauma
besides you know the adage
captain goes down with the ship right
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
star trek are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]